[Musique]
réfléchir aux territoires de demain
c'est l'objectif que s'est fixé
l'association terre et cité et la santa
clara va les open space authority la
semaine du 11 juillet une délégation
américaine composée par des élus et des
universitaires est conduite par le maire
de san jose en californie samedi cardo
s'est rendue sur le plateau de saclay
mois en fait on a invité à intervenir
pour rappeler les points clés vis-à-vis
de l'état du climat des projections et
puis les défis que ça pose en matière
d'adaptation un climat qui change on est
au moment d'une vague de chaleur les
enjeux en fait sur l'accélération du
rythme de baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et puis un hall la
multitude des attentes parfois
conflictuelles qu'on peut avoir
vis-à-vis de la manière dont on utilise
les terres
nos terres sont très chers et nous
subissons une quantité énorme de
pressions politiques et financières pour
le développement la
trouver ces chemins qui peuvent toujours
préservé et protégé
c'est jeudi seul à l'égard de toutes les
valeurs environnementales que ce soit
biodiversité la protection de l'eau la
faune et la flore sauvage ou quoi que ce
soit qui nous passionne on a besoin
d'être plus créatifs et cela veut dire
qu'on a besoin de mettre plus d'idées
sur la table comment ça sur ton que les
terres agricoles sont utilisés de la
manière la plus efficace mais en même
temps soutenir les agriculteurs pour que
les terres ne soit pas industrialisés
dans les années à venir vous pouvez
faire les deux vous pouvez protéger les
terres agricoles et ses espaces ouverts
tout en étant sensibles aux besoins de
construire des logements de protéger
l'industrie
comparez les idées et les actions de ces
deux territoires qui présente des défis
et opportunités similaires une véritable
richesse pour ces chercheurs élus et
acteurs du terrain français et américain
dans la silicon valley il ya une
urbanisation très importante et des
terres agricoles et naturels à préserver
ils ont mis en place leurs outils on a
mis en place les nôtres et on a un
échange expérience extrêmement
intéressant qui s'inscrit aussi dans le
changement climatique et des enjeux
forts à l'échelle de la planète c'est un
moment en fait je pense de
d'apprentissage collectif on va dire de
s'ouvrir sur d'autres approches d'autres
retours d'expérience mais aussi le ce
que j'ai compris des propos des élus
c'est quelque chose qui leur qui les
motive en fait qui les inscrit dans une
dynamique collective où chacun en fait
fait face à différentes formes
d'obstacles mais aussi en apprenant des
uns des autres parvient à les surmonter
à voir cette communauté de pratiques
autour du monde et reconnaître que nous
allons tous dans la même direction que
nous faisons partie d'une solution
commune ça donne de l'espoir ça donne
des partenaires des connaissances
techniques et des informations et ça
renforce des volontés politiques
ça nous aide à comprendre que nous
sommes pas seuls et que tout ça peut
nous accéléré me tuer un partenariat qui
veut inspirer de nouvelles actions
publiques concrètes après plusieurs
rencontres depuis 2016 dont une
invitation de l'open space authority un
sommet mondial sur l'action pour le
climat san francisco cette collaboration
franco-américaine compte bien continuer
dans les années à venir